ANDREW HUBERMAN: Welcome
to the Huberman Lab podcast
where we discuss science
and science-based tools
for everyday life.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I'm Andrew Huberman,
and I'm a professor
of neurobiology
and ophthalmology
at Stanford School of Medicine.
Today is an ask me
anything episode, or AMA.
This is part of our
premium subscriber channel.
Our premium subscriber
channel was started in order
to provide support for
the standard Huberman Lab
podcast, which comes
out every Monday
and is available at
zero-cost to everybody
on all standard feeds, YouTube,
Apple, Spotify and elsewhere.
We also started the
premium channel as a way
to generate support for exciting
research being done at Stanford
and elsewhere, research
on human beings that
leads to important
discoveries that
assist mental health, physical
health and performance.
I'm also pleased to inform
you that for every dollar
of the Huberman
Lab Premium channel
generates for research studies,
the Tiny Foundation has
agreed to match that amount.
So now we are able to double
the total amount of funding
given to studies of mental
health, physical health,
and human performance.
If you'd like to subscribe
to the Huberman Lab podcast
premium channel, please go
to hubermanlab.com/premium.
It is $10 a month to subscribe.
Or you can pay $100
all at once to get
an entire 12-month
subscription for a year.
We also have a lifetime
subscription model
that is a one-time payment.
And again, you can
find that option
at hubermanlab.com/premium.
For those of you that
are already subscribers
to the premium channel, please
go to hubermanlab.com/premium
and download the premium
subscription feed.
And for those of you that
are not Huberman Lab podcast
premium subscribers,
you can still
hear the first 20 minutes
of today's episode
and determine whether or not
becoming a premium subscriber
is for you.
Without further ado, let's get
to answering your questions.
The first question asks, is
it possible to get a cold
or to get sick from
deliberate cold exposure?
And I suppose a related
question is, should you even
do deliberate, cold
exposure if you have
a sniffle, a cold, or a flu?
I get that question
all the time as well.
So answer both of
those questions.
And I will also touch on some
of the immune enhancing effects
of deliberate cold exposure.
But just to make
sure that we answer
the specific question asked
here right off the bat,
is it possible to get a cold
or to get sick from deliberate
cold exposure?
Well, assuming that
you're not doing
the deliberate cold
exposure for more than,
say five or six
minutes at one stretch,
probably not directly from
the deliberate cold exposure.
I mention that
because most people
are doing anywhere
from about a minute
to three minutes, sometimes
five or six minutes.
And maybe for those
of you that are really
pushing it, 10 minutes of
deliberate cold exposure.
And most often after doing
that deliberate cold exposure,
people are either
getting clothed,
or they're getting into a sauna,
or they're taking a hot shower,
and then getting clothed and
heading off into their day
or off to sleep depending
on what time of day or night
you happen to do your
deliberate cold exposure.
We can safely say
that if you warm up
after a relatively brief,
meaning one minute to,
let's extend out to 10
minutes, 10-minute deliberate
cold exposure,
although, I really
want to caution people to
not do 10-minute deliberate
cold exposure right off the bat.
If you are somebody who
is not accustomed to it,
don't jump right up to that
long exposure to cold water.
Start with shorter exposures.
But if you're doing that
one-to-10-minute deliberate,
cold exposure, and then
you're getting warm afterwards
and heading about your day, I
can't see how the deliberate
cold exposure itself would
enhance your susceptibility
to getting sick.
That said, we know
from an enormous number
of studies that have looked
at cold virus transmission
and other forms of viral
and bacterial transmission
that the environment
that you happen to be in
does impact your
susceptibility to colds
and other types of viruses
and to bacterial infections
in the following way.
There have been controlled
studies in which people
go into laboratories.
Those laboratories have rooms,
which they can very tightly
control the humidity,
so essentially,
the water content
in the air, as well
as the temperature in the room.
And if you look at the
total mass of those data,
we can say a couple
of specific things
in kind of bullet point fashion.
First off, cold,
dry air does seem
to increase our
susceptibility to
viral and bacterial infections.
Because whether or not you're
a mouth breather or a nose
breather, and by the way, I
suggest everyone be a nose
breather unless you're
exercising hard enough that you
have to breathe
through your mouth,
or you're talking or
something of that sort.
But if you're a nose breather
or a mouth breather or both,
viruses and bacteria enter
through your nose and mouth,
sometimes through your eyes,
but your nose and mouth
are going to be the
main sites of entry
and your main barriers to
viral and bacterial infections.
In fact, one of the ways you
are constantly fighting off
bacterial and viral
infections that you're
exposed to all
the time is by way
of those viruses
and bacteria getting
trapped in the mucous
lining of your nose
or your mouth, most notably
in the back of your throat.
So if you spend time in
cold, dry environments,
there is a tendency for that
mucosal lining to be thinner.
There is a tendency
for that mucosal lining
to not be as robust in general.
And when I say
robust, what I mean
is that if your mouth
breathing, for instance
in a cold, dry environment,
I'm thinking from the time
I spent in Cambridge,
Massachusetts in winter
at the T station.
If you're I'm just
imagining myself
because it was so darn
cold back there breathing
through your mouth or
having gone for a run,
and your mouth isn't covered,
or even if you're deliberately
nasal breathing, you are
drying out your nasal passages
and making them more
susceptible to infections.
Does that necessarily
mean that every time you
go out in cold,
dry air that you're
going to get an infection?
No, of course it doesn't.
But to relate this back to
the question we have before,
there are a lot of data pointing
to the fact that more humid,
warm environments are going
to make your mucosal lining
and the general upper
respiratory area more,
I don't want to say
immune because I
don't want to conflate that
word with the other meaning
of immune.
It's going to make it
more robust against
bacterial and viral infections.
So if you get into a cold
shower or a cold plunge
or a cold ocean or a cold
lake, and then you get out,
and you're out there
shivering and shaking, trying
to boost your
metabolism or whatever
it is that you're
doing it for, and it's
cold, dry air, and
especially if your mouth
breathing in that
cold, dry air, yes, I
could see how that
might lead to a higher
probability of getting a cold
or other type of infection.
But there's nothing specific
about the deliberate, cold
exposure itself that can
induce a cold or other type
of infection assuming that
the water is clean, right?
We're not talking about
bacterial infections
of cuts on the skin, et cetera.
We're talking about colds and
other forms of being sick,
namely upper
respiratory infections.
OK, now with that said, I
often get asked whether or not
for people who already
have a little sniffle,
they're feeling a little run
down or perhaps a lot run down,
should they do
deliberate cold exposure?
And what's a little tricky
to give a one size fits all
answer, , but I think we can
safely say that if you are
feeling malaise, if you're
feeling like you have to rest
you're tired, you're not
feeling good because of a cold
or because of a flu or because
of a bacterial infection, now,
I'm not saying just
feeling not good,
I'm saying feeling not good
due to a cold or other form
of virus or bacterial infection,
then I would say stay out
of deliberate, cold exposure.
Don't use it.
Now, why would I say that?
Given the data I'll talk
about in a few minutes showing
that regular deliberate cold
exposure if done correctly,
can in fact increase
immune system markers
and perhaps even make you
much more robust to combating
different types of infection
through the release
of adrenaline.
We'll talk about what
all that looks like
in a moment in
terms of protocols
and some of the science.
But to just be very clear and
very direct, if you're sick,
stay out of deliberate
cold exposure.
There, I, would
instead recommend
warmer hot baths warmer hot
showers, the sauna, et cetera.
But I also would caution that
if you are getting into saunas
that are too hot,
saunas they're so
hot that it's stressful for
you, and again, a lot of people
use deliberate heat exposure
because of the stress
it induces, they're
doing some heat induced,
for instance, heat shock
proteins and different ways
of increasing heart rate.
That's a different
sort of thing.
That's hard, stressful in order
to generate an adaptation.
I don't recommend doing that.
In fact, I don't recommend
doing deliberate cold exposure,
exercise, or deliberate
heat exposure if you're
feeling really not well.
Now, if you're feeling
just a little bit not well,
you're feeling a little
bit rundown, a little bit
of sniffle, a little bit
of malaise, well then,
it's kind of an edge
case where we could
say, all right you know what?
Just take a hot shower
and go to sleep.
That's probably the best advice,
that good old-fashioned advice.
But if you are determined to do
your deliberate cold exposure
anyway, then I would
say definitely get warm
or take a hot shower afterwards,
hot bath, or hot sauna,
but, not too hot that
it's stressful, of course.
And keep in mind that one
of the variables that's
been measured quite
a lot in laboratory
studies of deliberate
cold exposure
is the increase in
immune system markers.
So I'll provide a few links
to some of these studies.
Although, nowadays there
are many, many of them.
But it's very clear that
deliberate cold exposure
can increase the release
and the production
of different immune
molecules and immune cells.
One slightly older study,
but nonetheless a good study
that has relevance
here is entitled
"Immune system of cold exposed
and cold adapted humans."
Keep in mind that this study
is a little bit extreme.
And there are reasons for that.
I guess to make a long
story short, oftentimes,
in order to quote unquote
"see an effect in a study,"
scientists will use conditions
that are pretty extreme
compared to control group.
Oftentimes, you'll see
a dose response to,
but it's a little bit trickier
to do with human studies
of deliberate, cold exposure.
It can be done,
but not too common.
But here, they
used a pretty what
I would call extreme stimulus.
It was exposing people to
14 degrees Celsius water,
so that's 57.2
degrees Fahrenheit,
which isn't that cold.
It's like cool, I would
say very cool water,
but not what you might
consider cold depending
on how well you tolerate cold.
And that will vary, of course.
But they had people exposed
to that for an hour, which
is a pretty long time.
Most people, as I mentioned,
are using colder temperatures
of deliberate cold
exposure, so even high 30s,
low 40s, maybe upper
40s for anywhere
from one to 10
minutes, depending
on how conditioned they are.
And again, don't just jump into
10 minutes of deliberate, cold
exposure, please at 35
degrees or 40 degrees
or even 45 degrees if you aren't
familiar with deliberate cold
exposure.
You have to ease into these
sorts of things over time.
And if you're
interested in protocols
for deliberate cold exposure,
we have a zero-cost newsletter
at hubermanlab.com.
Go to the Menu,
go to Newsletter,
and you can find that.
We've done several episodes
on deliberate cold exposure.
In any event, this study,
"Immune system of cold exposing
cold adapted humans,"
as I mentioned,
had people in 14 degrees
Celsius water for one hour.
And basically what they found
is that one exposure to cold
did not change immune
system function
in any kind of significant way.
However, what they found
was if people did deliver
cold exposure repeatedly over
a period of about six weeks,
and by repeatedly, I mean three
times per week, what they found
were trends.
And again, trends are not
statistically significant,
but trends towards increases in
plasma concentrations of things
like IL 6, interleukin 6 or
total numbers of T lymphocytes
and T helper cells
and T suppressor cells
and activated T
and B lymphocytes,
these are all immune
cells and immune molecules
that roughly correspond to
an increase in immune system
function.
If you'd like to learn more
about the immune system,
I did an episode on
immune system function.
Again, you can find
that at hubermanlab.com.
And it spells out
the basic cell types
of what's called the innate
and the adaptive immune system.
This study, which we will link
to in the show note captions
is but one study of several
other studies showing
that deliberate cold exposure
can increase immune system
markers, especially when
deliberate cold exposure is
done repeatedly over time,
so in this case, three times
a week over a
period of six weeks.
But again, I want to
highlight these aren't
highly significant effects.
These are trends
in the direction
of increased numbers of immune
cells and immune markers.
Now, what's
impossible to know is
how those trends translate
to actual resistance
to specific concentrations of,
say cold virus or flu virus
or any other virus or bacteria.
That would be great, but
that's a very difficult study
to do, especially in the context
of deliberate cold exposure
as well.
Now, we can all be scientists
about this and say, what is it
about deliberate cold
exposure that would increase
immune system function?
And there, we can
confidently say the molecules
epinephrine and
norepinephrine, which
are released in both brain and
body in response to cold water
exposure, as well as things like
deliberate hyperventilation,
the release of norepinephrine
and epinephrine into the brain
and body is known to have a
number of different effects
related to the immune system.
It can be pro-immune, at
least in the short term.
And in the long term, meaning
if noradrenaline and adrenaline,
again those are just different
names for norepinephrine
and epinephrine.
I'm sorry, those
are the same thing,
but that's why I use
them interchangeably so
that you don't get confused.
If you see noradrenaline
or norepinephrine,
that's the same thing you hear,
epinephrine or adrenaline,
same thing.
Deliberate cold exposure or
deliberate hyperventilation
will increase those molecules,
norepinephrine and epinephrine.
And their increase
is pro-immune.
It can trigger the
activation of immune cells
and immune molecules
that can make
you more resistant to
certain forms of infection.
However, if norepinephrine
and epinephrine
are elevated chronically,
and especially
if they are elevated late
in the day repeatedly
over many, many days,
that can cause reductions
in the number and
efficiency of immune cells
in combating infections.
So getting cold
in this context of
whether or not you
can get sick from it
should really be
considered more as
what happens when you spike your
adrenaline and norepinephrine?
And there's one other
study that we can look to,
which is now really a famous
study published in proceedings
of the National
Academy of Sciences
looking at so-called
Wim Hof breathing.
But really, that just translates
to cyclic hyperventilation.
So this is inhaling
through nose,
exhaling through the mouth
repeatedly 25 times or so.
[BREATHING]
If you do that, you notice
you feel quite warm,
lots to do with some things
relate to vasodilation,
has some things to do with
release of norepinephrine.
And epinephrine, we
know that pattern
of deliberate hyperventilation,
much like deliberate
cold exposure,
deploys or releases
noradrenaline and adrenaline
into your brain and body.
And we know from
this study entitled
"Voluntary activation of the
sympathetic nervous system
and attenuation of the innate
immune response in humans"
showed really nicely, I think.
That if people are injected
with E. coli, a bacteria
it's actually an
end-- they did this
through endotoxin injections.
People got really sick.
They'd get feel like
they had the flu,
they vomit, diarrhea,
get a fever, et cetera.
However if they did
the sorts of breathing
that I talked about just a
moment ago, prior to that,
they were able to ward off a
lot of the symptoms associated
with the endotoxin infection.
And you would say, OK wow, their
immune system just fired up,
and they were able
to fight it off.
But it's trickier
than that, actually.
What happened was the
release of epinephrine
and norepinephrine from
cyclic hyperventilation, which
is really what
[BREATHING] really
is, cyclic hyperventilation,
also called Wim Hof breathing,
also called tummo breathing,
et cetera, that actually had
a suppressive action on certain
arms of the immune system
in a way that allowed
people to avoid symptomology
such as fever,
nausea, et cetera.
And we would imagine
the same thing would
occur with deliberate
cold exposure done
prior to bacterial
infection or viral exposure.
So if you're sensing that I'm
saying two things at once,
I am.
I'm saying deliberate
cold exposure,
and cyclic hyperventilation
can both cause deployment
of molecules such as
epinephrine and norepinephrine
that lead to enhanced
immune system
function if done repeatedly.
I'm also saying that increasing
norepinephrine and epinephrine
too much can suppress
your immune system.
In this study, the PNAS study
that I mentioned a moment ago,
that suppression of
the immune response
was actually one of the reasons
people avoided symptomology.
But they were still
injected with endotoxin,
so they just weren't fighting
off the endotoxin with fever.
Remember, fever is an
adaptation to fight infection.
It's designed essentially
to heat up the infection
and kill it.
So what are we to
take away from this?
Here are what I think
are the key takeaways.
One, if you are
feeling good to great,
do your deliberate
cold exposure.
And perhaps don't worry so
much about using your body's
natural metabolism and
thermogenic abilities
to heat back up afterwards.
But I don't suggest anyone
ever allow themselves
to stay really cold
after deliberate
cold exposure for more than
10, 15 minutes or maybe
half an hour, right?
Get bundled back up,
or put on clothes.
If it's a nice hot, sunny day,
get out in the sun and warm up.
Again, temperatures
and conditions
will vary for different people,
different locations, et cetera.
If you are not
feeling great, you're
feeling a little
rundown, and you really
want to do your
deliberate cold exposure,
do it, but then warm up
really well afterwards.
Maybe even drink some hot tea or
other fluid afterwards as well.
And if you are not feeling
good, you're feeling malaise,
you're feeling run down.
Despite what you read
about deliberate,
cold exposure or cyclic
hyperventilation,
allowing for the deployment
of immune molecules
or increasing the
number of immune cells
that you're making,
avoid anything
that's stressful or
challenging whether or not
it's a cold challenge, a heat
challenge, or an exercise
challenge when you're
feeling run down.
Because under those conditions,
what you really want to do
is slow your circulation
down, probably
find and take a little
walks or something
provided you're not doubled
over in bed and vomiting,
and things like that.
A little bit of
movement, probably
good to circulate your blood.
But in general,
the advice that you
get to rest when you're
sick and not push yourself,
that's really good
advice because you
want all of your
body's resources
to be devoted to getting
over that infection.
And if you're interested
in sickness and sickness
behavior and the
sorts of behaviors
that can combat infection,
check out the episode
I did on the immune system.
We'll link to it in
the show note captions.
Because it talks
about how when we
have a viral or
bacterial infection,
a whole set of
brain circuits get
activated that encourage us to
be more in the fetal position,
to move less, to be eyes
down, to kind of slump down.
That's not a coincidence.
That's because of the activation
of these so-called sickness
circuits that are
really designed
to help you heal yourself.
So I both apologize, and
what do the kids say?
Sorry, not sorry.
Don't apologize for the
somewhat nuanced answer here.
Because a lot of
information out there says,
oh, cold boosts
your immune system.
And yeah, that's true
under certain conditions.
It can also deplete
your immune system
and limit your ability
to fight off infections
under other conditions.
And perhaps the last
thing to say about this
is that I am a big believer in
using nasal breathing whenever
you don't have to breathe
through your mouth.
So if you're exercising
hard, by all means breathe
through your mouth.
If you're doing
martial arts, and it
requires that you breathe
through your mouth,
go ahead and do that.
But if you're doing, say a
zone two cardio, low level
cardio, or you're
just walking along,
it's very clear based on
a growing amount of data
that being a nasal
breather is better
than being a mouth breather.
And there are a number
of different reasons
for that we've talked about
on the podcast and elsewhere.
But one of the additional
reasons is a main site of entry
for infections is
through the mouth.
So keep that mouth shut
unless you need to talk.
Thank you for joining
for the beginning of this
ask me anything episode.
To hear the full episode and to
hear future episodes of these
ask me anything sessions, plus
to receive transcripts of them
and transcripts of the Huberman
Lab podcast standard channel
and premium tools not released
anywhere else please go
to hubermanlab.com/premium.
Just to remind you why we
launched the Huberman Lab
podcast premium channel
it's really twofold.
First of all, it's
to raise support
for the standard Huberman
Lab podcast channel, which
of course, will still be
continued to be released
every Monday in full length.
We are not going to
change the format
or anything about the
standard Huberman Lab podcast
and to fund research,
in particular, research
done on human beings,
so not animal models
but on human beings,
which I think we all agree
is the species that we
are most interested in.
And we are going to
specifically fund
research that is aimed
toward developing
further protocols for mental
health, physical health,
and performance.
And those protocols
will be distributed
through all channels, not
just the premium channel,
but through all channels,
Huberman Lab podcast
and other media channels.
So the idea here is to give
you information to your burning
questions in depth and
allow you the opportunity
to support the kind
of research that
provides those kinds of
answers in the first place.
Now, an especially exciting
feature of the premium channel
is that the Tiny
Foundation has generously
offered to do dollar
for dollar match
on all funds raised for research
through the premium channel.
So this is a terrific
way that they're
going to amplify whatever funds
come in through the premium
channel to further support
research for science
and science related tools, for
mental health, physical health,
and performance.
If you'd like to sign up for the
Huberman Lab premium channel,
again, there's a cost
of $10 per month,
or you can pay $100 up
front for the entire year.
That will give you
access to all the AMAs
you can ask questions and get
answers to your questions.
And you'll of course get
answers to all the questions
that other people ask as well.
There will also be some premium
content such as transcripts
of the AMAs and various
transcripts and protocols
of Huberman Lab podcast episodes
and not found elsewhere.
And again, you'll be
supporting research
for mental health, physical
health, and performance.
You can sign up for the
premium channel by going
to hubermanlab.com/premium.
Again, that's
hubermanlab.com/premium.
And as always, thank you for
your interest in science.
[MUSIC PLAYING]